[Applause]
beautiful you look beautiful just in my
dressing room
oh really that's where you do it those
good you know each other though right
yeah Israel together called the creative
coalition it's a kind of a bunch of
artists and the industry people went to
Israel and can we just tell the hot what
the highlight for me was we climbed
Masada is this you know the ancient
fortress and one of the big things is he
you do this really steep long hot hike
and everybody was ready and everybody
had their [ __ ] you know their their
beers here and you know Tichina comes by
and she's looking beautiful I'm not
exaggerating wearing heels okay and her
bag and her bag had a pocketbook we can
live two weeks off in my pocket just
amazing beautiful this beautiful woman
in heels walking up this deadly hike to
an ancient fortress that's my favorite I
did it I did you know what it was just
such a wonderful experience and then
even you know uh getting in the Dead Sea
yeah that's right I've always wanted to
do that agostic it should be the eighth
wonder of the world it's something
really amazing but we had a good time
we're we're we're buddies just can't
shave before you go into the deads yeah
skin it oh that would burn ha ha
I'm just gonna let you know though mama
doesn't wear heels unless I'm being paid
so
no but you a classic sitcom that I loved
as well
my yeah with Shanaya whole show I
thought it was so good so what other
than people being a fool like me and
just singing the song Martin what do
people do they still come up to you and
ask you about that oh man I got my name
is but you know what's what's gratifying
for me is to know that I did a show you
know 28 years ago and people still enjoy
it yeah God has blessed me to do what I
love doing and being on Martin all those
years we just really had a good time and
for us to see people laugh at it this
laughter makes the world go around and
[Applause]
yes and I'm happy I finally made it to
your dance schmuck no did they speak
well of us were they like that came back
to the set and she was like oh my god I
love Kelly Kelly oh I had so much fun of
the show yeah she loved it they all did
you know she introduced me to Marie
Kondo and then Marie Kondo came on the
show we had her back yes and I do you
know Marie called about Beth is in love
with her but outside I thought Beth was
nuts
I never cuz just that part cuz I was
like what is this Marie kind of thing
I've never heard of it
I am obsessed yeah I'm a little OCD too
so it works like I'll organize me I've
been true ever since I had my daughter
which was 15 years ago I'm still trying
to organize my life children they change
your life yeah ever in a good way but
and also other ways yes sometimes just
tornadoes yeah told me about his
neighborhood so what was yours like
Greta okay you know I was want to raise
in Jamaica Queens
we have a lot of great people a lot of
talented people but I've lived in a
small like I couldn't go past a
one-block radius so everybody everything
was according to your block what block
did you live life and so when rap came
out you know we were able to hear rap
songs from the Bronx and Brooklyn so you
knew what was that was that's what rap
was about but yeah we're from Queens
during the 90s and the 80s it was just
it was a good neighborhood
yeah I walked I was a little kid I would
walk in people's doors I everybody left
the door unlocked and we bought each
other's kids
so yeah but it's a very blue-collar
borough
you know with amazing diversity it's it
was never the coolest borough but now
it's got the best food amazing
neighborhood since I always tell people
whenever you land at JFK I live like
seven blocks okay I remember the big
planes would come in at night the
Concorde would come in really really
really windows rattle my whole house
would shake we had a train behind us so
you know we I think we all have similar
neighborhoods in a way where it is about
community yeah you know a neighborhood
is all always about community and even
if you don't know someone like I try to
make you know a difference by not being
shut off from people and if I get new
neighbors I'm like hey how you doing I'm
you know yeah you know I may not be
fearful of something you may not know
but do not feel feel I just want to make
sure that you try to steal my stuff
[Laughter]
[Music]
early identification program your
daughter is almost 16 what she like is
that I we have a three five 13 and 18
year olds I mean if you lost me after
the second one yeah yeah I think yeah a
teenager that can be trying oh my god
just keep us in your prayers my daughter
she it's hard to watch herself she's
like watching now that she's older is
like watching myself it's scary but what
I'm so grateful to God for is that I'm a
woman and I can teach her how to be a
woman
yeah had I had a male child a little
bitterness yeah I was a single mom which
I did not expect to be I didn't have her
until I was 35 years old had already had
career first and then kind of you know
just you know got into motherhood and I
think it's been the most gratifying and
amazing and just rocky road that I've
ever taken in my life but she's that one
person that I would die without in the
blink of an eye for yeah so it's it's
motherhood first and then everything
else yeah there's so much love it's yes
sometimes I'm like you gotta love you
but I don't like you right now
for your safety you should leave my
presence that's because they didn't know
us before we were mothers god bless you
I think it's wonderful loving them I
never thought I'd be one my mom is still
like oh my god you have children and a
husband Gina you've got away this is my
favorite thing I've ever heard with
parenting you've got away with your
daughter to kind of punish her and it
deals with a cell phone almost
definitely we live in the day and age
where you know everything we all have
cell phones it's like you know we are
attached to our devices and you know I
tried taking the cell phone away from
her which you know it wasn't really
advantageous for me because she takes
over sometimes and we need the cell
phone so okay I'm gonna get you a flip
phone I got and now everything goes
through my phone you know so I know how
to shut her down when I need to there's
a way of punishing someone without you
know not having contact with them we
could still have contact but I had to
give her a flip phone because but I love
that you control I when she's
with her friends and she pulls out her
Ferris Bueller fall back to subscribe to
my channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel please don't make me keep going